what is a libertarian i mean i have my
definition of what a libertarian is i've
read the definition
online with a libertarian as i've seen
joe jorgensen's definition of
libertarianism
what is your definition of a libertarian
i'm okay with joe jorgensen's it's
the government governs best that governs
least okay
that we need some government you need
government to protect us from
foreign invaders uh something the
founders hadn't thought of i would say
we need government for pollution rules
because
my smoke goes to your lungs there's no
market incentive to behave well
you could sue me but our legal system's
so slow that's impractical
so we need government to do some things
but government is a blunt instrument
and it doesn't do anything well
you would your radio show you can't your
podcast you constantly have to adjust to
what the market
wants what the viewers listeners want
every business does
every second in government they make an
adjustment once every two years or four
years
if then and often to make an adjustment
it's illegal because they passed all
these rules to see if you wouldn't
steal the money germany and japan
prospered
after why in the 60s and 70s
because we'd bombed them to smithereens
and they had to start over without all
their little rules
less government creates prosperity and
that makes
everybody's life better what's the
difference between libertarian and
republican
uh i i think homosexuality
is just fine i don't think people should
be
forced to salute the flag i don't think
and this is now a democrat thing too i
don't think we should try to police the
world
don't see why i thought we won against
japan and germany but we have
50 000 soldiers stationed in germany
thirty thousand in japan
uh often we make enemies we have troops
in
almost a hundred countries often we make
more enemies than we
keep the peace i think that drugs should
be legal
not just marijuana today's 420. i don't
know what are your thoughts on
legalization of marijuana well i i'm sad
to see
that uh who was it willie willie
nelson willie nelson wants the president
to make it a national holiday
a national week do we have to make
everything about government can't you
just enjoy weed
but it's once you're an adult do you own
your body
or not isn't it my right you've got your
tequila here if i want to poison myself
with your tequila
that's the rock's tequila shout out to
the rocks should be our choice
right so that's a libertarian by the way
if they make 420
a national holiday for wheat 420 also
happens to be hitler's birthday
so before they decide to make 420 a
national holiday they might want to
think twice
on making the man's birthday
a national flipping holiday may not be a
good idea i agree with you good point i
did not know that yeah
420 can you imagine that you make that
the birthday it's it's a pretty pathetic
situation
part of uh libertarianism is the the
belief in
laissez-faire economics yes what are
your
what are your thoughts on that let's i
mean it's essentially do as you will do
as you please let let the markets be
what just happened if you don't cheat
and
someone's not muted i hear the audio of
the episode i don't
i do what are you guys here okay go
ahead just keep going it's okay part of
laissez faire i hear the uh
episode on the background and it's not
mine i lord my audio
is it yours nope
you're not hearing it i'm hearing you
now but go ahead folks if you're hearing
it as well let us know if you're hearing
the background or not but uh
go ahead continue adam go ahead laid
fair capitalism laissez faire economics
it just means that let us be and
it doesn't mean do whatever you want
because as i said you got to please the
customer for things to work well
you need a deed to your property the
worst places to live are say
the african country where there's no
rule of law
because no one builds the factory
because if you do
people may steal what you make or the
dictator may take your whole factory
so you need to know that what you own is
yours and then you'll build on it
some economists have gone into the slums
of latin america and
and tried to figure out why do these
people stay poor
well it's because they can't know that
their home is their home
so they don't improve it they don't
improve the store
because they don't own their property
but once you own it and you know and
there are rules against
cheating then that's what creates wealth
that's
yeah that's part of the libertarian
doctrine yeah yeah so
why doesn't the libertarian party have a
bigger place in america
we've talked about on the show that you
know you've got the left on the job
cannot tell me joe jorgensen's going to
inspire you yeah like why
joe jorgensen gary you gave her a nice
shout out and gary johnson a nice shout
out
the energy of libertarians is driving me
insane like you know what we need to do
we need to get libertarians to be
sponsored by red bull
by bang by starbucks sure buy dunkin
donuts pick whatever coffee you got
sponsor some of these libertarians with
some energy i don't even drink coffee
but i think they need a little bit of it
because they're definitely not
it's a great concept that could resonate
with the younger audience
but it's not being sold properly but
energy isn't enough
ron paul was energetic and he converted
a lot though he did convert a lot of
people but
people are not comfortable with freedom
just
a lot of people something's different
about our brains that we're sympathetic
to these ideas
i don't know i don't even know what you
mean by that what do you mean that
people aren't comfortable with freedom i
think people really enjoy their freedom
job
they're scared they're worried if if
people can do whatever they want the
rich will abuse the poor
the strong will abuse the weak uh
people it won't be able to pay their
hospital bills
poor people will get screwed it's just
easier to believe that if you elect wise
people who want to help people
for each according to his ability each
according to his need that that will be
better
my own wife who's listened to my stories
for
38 years now still says
but wait a second what about this and
this is
the poor people are going to be left
behind here it's not it
once i learned it it was just clear to
me but
most people will never either spend the
time to learn it
or they can't learn it so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye